in the Tunisian Port of spax a graveyard
of Broken Dreams
these boats once packed with migrants
have been intercepted by the Coast Guard
and ordered back to shore
but those who were on board will almost
certainly try to reach Europe again
they've come too far to turn back
Michael a university student has led
fighting in Sudan
his group trekked across the deserts of
Libya and Algeria and into Tunisia we're
in Winter inside in case you are caught
in that at the border point you will end
up regretting at the same thing likewise
to Libya whenever you are caught you
will face a lot of challenges you will
end up in jail or sometimes should you
date we lost a lot of Life along the way
these migrants hope to join more than 42
000 others who've made the journey so
far this year across the central
Mediterranean to Europe
Ibraham is from the Ivory Coast and
knows the risks of Crossing all too well
my brother died in the sea but it's not
me seven boats can sink but one boat can
make it it was their Destiny To Die In
The Water I'm not afraid
like almost everyone else Abraham knows
someone who's made it to Europe that's
the future he wants for his wife and
two-month-old daughter
God willing I've been told it's not that
easy but since birth nothing is easy you
have to face reality
that reality includes a 200 kilometer
Crossing from Tunisia to lampedusa the
closest European land
migrants can be at sea for 14 hours or
more before landing somewhere here if
they've not been intercepted
since January there's been a near 300
increase in migrant arrivals here
compared to the same time last year
that's according to the European Union
and this route accounts for more than
half the irregular Crossings into the EU
this year and it's not yet even summer
when Karma weather encourages more
Crossings
burnersmith Al Jazeera lampedusa Italy